gentlemen this between the two of you
you have so much adventure under your
belt tons and tons of adventure under
your belt but
with this trip you know you're kind of
doing the a new frontier
with going everything electric
you know i was curious about how much
your expectations
of what this was going to be uh
met up with with like full force with
the reality of what was happening
uh in every situation and every
challenge you had to face
wow okay no it's a good question it's
good
i think i think i think we we our prep
once we decided to go electric we'd of
course we went we had to
learn as much as we could about it you
know and trying to find the right bike
with to give us the
you know the longest range the fastest
charging
and we were lucky to settle on the
harley davidson live wire which was not
yet in production
and then we asked harley-davidson if
they would
build a version of their livewire for us
that was a
dual sports bike so that was easy better
for riding off-road as well because we
had bolivia to go through and we had
some sections of our trip that were very
rough road riding rough riders charlie
yeah
and um so they did they did they did
this amazing job they
really nailed it they put the bike was
amazing to ride
but because the time frame we didn't get
the bike until we were there
in usual in the south southern tip of
argentina and so by that time we'd had
no testing on the bike we had no idea
on what speed to write it at what you
know what the effect of temperature
would be on the
batteries that the effect of uh
headwinds would be on the batteries
so we learned to all on the hoof you
know we were snowbound down there for a
week before we could leave
and then there was a gap in the snow and
we went like go go we got out of there
and we got on the trip
and then we started going okay we don't
know anything like we ride at 45 miles
an hour do we write a 55 miles an hour
so it was all experimentation to begin
with and and
to your point that it was it was a bit
scary at first because we thought
we might not be you know it was very
very cold and so the bikes didn't charge
quickly and they also didn't hold their
charge very well because of the
temperature
and then so we just there were days we
thought we might not be able to do it
that maybe we won't be able to get there
you know if we can only do
100 miles a day this is going to take us
a long long time but we got better at it
the temperatures go
warmer and we just learned how to sort
of
navigate the the was doing a lot we're
always doing a lot of mathematics
but in the end it was a very positive
experience and
and we wouldn't choose to have gone any
other way it was really a cool
way to meet people by asking can we plug
into your house and
you plug into people's houses and while
the bike's charging you get a few hours
to hang around with those
new people and it was always a positive
experience yeah
it's it's really a joy to watch you guys
just enjoy
riding just enjoy being out there with
regards to
um accidents you know i have a friend
that said
it's not a matter of if it's a matter of
when
you know a motorcycle accident will
happen and then what you do next
and charlie yours were awful the
you know what you've gone through and in
your journey back to being able to get
on the bike how did that affect you
mentally when it came to the idea of
taking this long trip did it at all
i think yeah sure i i got really unlucky
and had a big crash in
in 2016 and i smashed my legs up and
and quite badly and and um and you know
i think everybody was
was quite worried and and certainly i
was at the beginning and
and but i remember going through a lot
of surgery
um that you know the night of the
accident and i i woke up the next
morning and
and i looked at my and myself in the on
the bed and i
and both my legs were wearing bandages
and my
right hand was in a bandage and and i
think i was feeling
extremely sorry for myself and i was
thinking my gosh what's what's going to
happen to me
and and i was sharing a room with
another guy and
and the other guy in the bed was was was
was in a much much worse state than i
was i mean he was
in a terrible state and i just turned
around and i looked at myself and i
thought you know what it's actually
it's not it's not that bad it's going to
take me a while but but
i'm going to recover and i think from
that point on i i i could see the future
and i thought you know
and then i used i used the idea of
getting back on the motorbike as
my therapy as my as my challenge as my
goal
and and um and then you know i because
of the action and you and i
had kind of drifted back together again
and and we and we
and we uh and we started chatting more
we started
chatting about maybe doing another trip
and and i think all those things
really helped me uh get back on the on
the go but
you know getting out on the on on the
road i never
really it didn't cross my mind that
that that i couldn't do it mm-hmm but
you also didn't you also didn't let it
get in your
head you know when we when it did get
rough we when believe we got into
bolivia and the roads were really
difficult they were you get when you're
riding off-road the roads can become
corrugated and um the roads in bolivia
were
just unbelievably corrugated so we're
riding just being shaken to pieces and
we hit a patch of deep sand
the front wheel goes and you know for
charlie that could be that
could end up really very badly but very
simple
off just the wrong way could really
damage charlie's already damaged legs
so it was incredibly ballsy of you to
just
get keep going and we're both you know
we can we can speak to each other in our
helmets while we're riding along we've
got
your you know got radios in there so
every every five minutes one of us is
going oh
that's so funny but surely like the
the stakes were super high and um
yeah i thought it was very brave of you
you just never you didn't let it sort of
you just got on with it and i i thought
that was amazing well then that's very
kind
uh you know but i think it's because we
all just love
riding motorcycles and and you know it's
it's it's a
i mean urine broke his leg just before
he went off a long way down and and
you know i remember him turning up at
the at
we had this big warehouse that we were
getting getting the
the trip ready from and something he
turns up in this in this in this
in this plastic boot and that and he
comes walking in and i
hate you and he goes oh hurry and and he
gets on this bike and i go oh
where are you going in that because oh
well i had to i've got need to
the bike needs to be run and uh and
and off he went and i said oh it's not a
bit quick to be on the bike
no no no i think it's all good and and
off he went
so i think i think most people who like
motorbikes are
you know i don't suppose a bit like
people who ride horses as well
you know you the amount of people got
broken bones and they all get back on
again so you know i think it's your
passion and
you can never let it go